get ready come on ghouls the ghoul from
Monster High are back in an all-new
electrifying movie presents Clawdeen
Wolf their electric baton pack we're
really setting Smith what's your biggest
dream let's turn the power station into
a soul on a plate for everybody
humans and monsters alike well it
started with a monster vision and a dash
of monster style I can see it now
but to bring their dreams of life the
pools will need a spark a little
lightning never heard anybody of
inspiration this is what my a blessing
how Stella station salon deserves
electric fashion you're stealing all the
electricity and they say thank you the
boo with all the brains no there aren't
any break all Claudine and her friends
have to do cool let's move is bring
everyone together look at all these
monsters for one voltageous opening
night here's one is all over the
Internet monster style is the next big
thing Monster High electrified come back
to the school where all are welcome
nothing stops a night of these dogs
voice hey somebody please help him an
all new movie coming to blu-ray DVD and
digital
you